ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome
to the Huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today is an Ask Me
Anything episode, or AMA.
This is part of our
premium subscriber channel.
Our premium subscriber
channel was started in order
to provide support for
the standard Huberman Lab
podcast, which comes
out every Monday
and is available at
zero cost to everybody
on all standard feeds, YouTube,
Apple, Spotify, and elsewhere.
We also started the
premium channel as a way
to generate support for exciting
research being done at Stanford
and elsewhere, research
on human beings that
leads to important
discoveries that
assist mental health, physical
health, and performance.
I'm also pleased to inform
you that for every dollar
of the Huberman
Lab Premium channel
generates for research studies,
the tiny foundation has
agreed to match that amount.
So now we are able to double
the total amount of funding
given to studies of mental
health, physical health,
and human performance.
If you'd like to subscribe
to the Huberman Lab podcast
premium channel, please go
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
It is $10 a month to subscribe,
or you can pay $100 all at once
to get an entire 12-month
subscription for a year.
We also have a lifetime
subscription model
that is a one-time payment.
And, again, you can
find that option
at hubermanlab.com/premium.
For those of you that
are already subscribers
to the premium channel, please
go to hubermanlab.com/premium
and download the premium
subscription feed.
And for those of you that
are not Huberman Lab podcast
premium subscribers,
you can still
hear the first 20 minutes
of today's episode
and determine whether or not
becoming a premium subscriber
is for you.
And now without further ado,
I will answer your questions.
And as always, I
will strive to be
as thorough as possible,
as clear as possible,
and as concise as possible.
The first question
is about eye health,
in particular eye
health protocols
for people that are aging
but eye health protocols
for people in general.
The question is, I'm
noticing that my vision,
both close and far,
is deteriorating.
What are the best eye
exercises, eye health behaviors,
supplements, et cetera
for the aging eye?
So the answer I'm
about to provide
applies to everybody
regardless of age,
which is, you want to make sure
that you view things both close
up and far away across your day.
Many, many people nowadays
spend a lot of time
looking at their smartphone,
looking at the computer screen,
looking at books and
paper, in other words,
looking at things somewhere
between 9 inches away
from their face and their
eyes, maybe 2 and 1/2 feet away
from their face and eyes.
This is an unprecedented
event in human history,
as far as we know,
because it wasn't
until the advent
of the smartphone
that we've spent so much
time looking at screens
at close range
relative to looking
at things at further
distances from our face
throughout the day.
In fact, it should
come as no surprise
that the incidence of
myopia, of nearsightedness,
is increasing dramatically
around the world
but is increasing
particularly fast in children
and in young adults
and even in adults
who are viewing things at very
close range, so 2 and 1/2 feet
or less.
Now, I am not saying
that viewing things
at 2 and 1/2 feet or less is bad
for your eyes, that is simply
not the case.
However, if you want your
vision to be maintained or even
improve, it's going
to be very important
for you to view
things at a distance
as well for ideally
several hours per day.
Now, I realize some people just
simply won't accomplish this.
In fact, I'd like everyone
to just take a moment
and do a rough
estimation in your head
of how much time during
your daytime activities
you are viewing things at,
say, 2 and 1/2 feet or 3
feet or less, so
smartphone, computer screen,
paper, books, et cetera,
versus viewing things
that are 4 feet
away, 8 feet away,
so maybe conversation across the
table with another human being.
Remember those?
Some of us are
doing that more now
that we seem to be emerging
from this whole pandemic phase.
However, many people are
still mostly just viewing
things within very close range.
And, in fact, if you were to
ask yourself, how much time do
you spend looking at things at
the distance of many hundreds
of feet, or taking a walk
where you're not looking
at any screen and
you're simply letting
visual images or
the visual imagery
rather pass by on your
eyes, I think for most of us
that number is getting
progressively smaller
and smaller with
each passing year.
So this is an issue because
the structure of the eye
is such that the lens
of the eye can move,
but also that the length of
the eyeball from front to back
is actually impacted
by how close
or how far you
happen to view things
during the course of your day,
especially during development.
There's a classic
experiment that I'd
like to just briefly
describe to you which
has been performed in chickens.
It's been performed in mice.
It's also been
performed on humans,
where a visual occluder
or a visual image.
So an occluder is just a black
screen or a piece of cardboard
or an image, maybe some black
and white checks or checkers,
are placed at a certain
distance from the eye,
either up close or far
away, and the impact
of that on the
length of the eyeball
and on the structure of the lens
and on the quality and acuity
of vision is then measured.
And to make a long story short,
what these studies show is
that, if during development,
you or an animal
exclusively looks at things
that are up close, very
close to the eye, and doesn't
ever get long-range vision,
the eyeball lengthens.
And when that happens the
lens, which, of course, is
in the front of
the eyeball, which
focuses the light onto
the back of the eyeball,
which is where the
so-called neural retina
is, where the cells
that sense light are,
that visual image
lands in front of as
opposed to directly on
the light-sensing portion
of the eyeball that we
call the neural retina.
It lands too close or near
the lens as opposed to
on the back of the eyeball.
And that's part
of the reason what
we call the consequence of
that nearsighted myopia.
In far sightedness,
the opposite happens.
The visual image is actually
focused behind the retina.
It doesn't land directly on the
retina, which is what you want.
It's focused too far
behind the retina.
And that's due to a
shortening of the eyeball.
So what I just
described actually
explains pretty well why kids
who look at computer screens,
or books up close
often need glasses.
When I was growing up, they
called this nerd syndrome.
Raising my hand for those
of you that are listening.
I read an awful lot, but I also
spend time outside fortunately
and running around
on the soccer field
and looking at things
in the distance
and playing in the
neighborhood with my friends.
Kids that spend the vast
amount of their time looking
at things up close,
and particularly
children who do that indoors
for most of their waking time,
well, those kids develop myopia.
This is part of
the reason why we
have such an increase of the
incidence of myopia nowadays.
What's interesting, and I think
most people don't realize,
is that even as a young adult
and adult, and perhaps even as
an older adult,
an elderly person,
looking at things up close to
much at the expense of getting
some time viewing
things at a distance,
in particular outdoors, can
be very problematic because it
can exacerbate myopia.
So the short,
direct prescription
here is to make sure that you're
getting at least an hour or so
each day, although ideally it
would be more, of long viewing.
And that could be done by
walking outside and avoiding
looking at your
phone while walking.
It doesn't require that you
look at a particular object
in the distance, although if
you are scanning for and looking
for objects in the distance,
the way that you might on a hike
or you're looking out
toward or off a vista
or you're looking for
someone in the distance,
all of that sort of
visual scanning behavior
is going to be very
good for your eye health
and for maintaining
vision at a distance.
If you're somebody
who's far sighted
and you have trouble
seeing things up close,
well, then you need to ask
yourself whether or not
you're spending too much
time looking at things off
in the distance, although
I want to be very
clear that nearsightedness
and farsightedness aren't
necessarily the consequence
of this near, far viewing.
There can be independent
causes of nearsightedness
and farsightedness.
But for many people
out there who
are spending progressively
more and more time just looking
at things up close, you
can get this lengthening
of the eyeball or
challenges in the way
that the elasticity of
the lens is controlled
by the musculature
in ways that make
it hard to maintain sharp,
crisp vision when you're
looking at things at a
distance or up close.
So I can't, because there
are simply no studies
to support the idea that you
need exactly two hours per day
of outside long vision at a
particular distance and/or
that you want to cut off
or have a threshold of four
hours per day of looking
at things up close,
but we can say with a
high degree of confidence
that if you want to
maintain or enhance
your vision at all distances,
that for every hour or so
that you spend
looking at things,
say, a distance of
3 feet away or less,
that you want to get at least
one hour per day total, doesn't
have to be all at once,
of looking at things
out in the distance
or looking at things beyond 3
feet relative to the distance
from your eye.
So I think for some people
who are already badly myopic,
this isn't going to
remedy that myopia.
You're still going to
need corrective lenses,
but if you're somebody,
similar to the person who
asks the question, that they're
quote unquote "noticing"
their vision is
deteriorating, really
try and balance out
the amount of viewing
that you're doing at close
distance and long distance.
And, again, I would not obsess
about the total numbers.
It doesn't have to be three
hours and three hours,
but the more time that you
can spend at viewing things
that variable distance
throughout the day,
the better off you're going to
be in maintaining and perhaps
even enhancing your
vision somewhat.
Now, there's an
additional behavioral tool
that we can glean from the
recent scientific literature
exploring myopia which
points to the fact
that children who get
two hours a day or more
of time outside in sunlight--
one of my favorite topics.
I know many people are
probably rolling their eyes
right now when they
hear me say you really
want to view morning
sunlight, not
through a window or windshield.
Don't wear sunglasses for that,
trying to get as much sunlight
as you can in your
eyes early in the day.
Never stare at any light
so bright it's painful,
look at, et cetera.
We've done a lot of
episodes on this.
We have a Light
for Health episode,
this Isn't All the
Sleep episodes.
It's just such a
basic foundation
of circadian rhythm and health
that I just keep repeating it.
However, there are also
large-scale clinical trials
involving thousands
of subjects that
have shown that people,
children in particular, who
get two hours or more of
outside time every day
have a much lower
incidence of myopia.
Now, what's really interesting
about these studies is that,
while some of those kids are
looking at things further
off in the distance than they
would if they were indoors
on their tablets or screens
or with their nose in a book,
it does not seem to
be the case that they
have to be looking at
things in the distance
in order to see this
reduced incidence of myopia.
What's probably
happening instead
is that the
particular wavelengths
of light that
emanate from the sun,
that photon energy in
particular is triggering
the activation of the
so-called intrinsically
sensitive melanopsin and retinal
ganglion cells, which we know
are important for setting
circadian rhythm for enhancing
mood focus and
alertness during the day
and enhancing the quality and
duration of sleep at night.
But those melanopsin and
intrinsically photosensitive
ganglion cells are also
involved in networks
within the eye that
relate to blood flow, that
relate to the
ciliary body, which
is a structure within the eye
that controls the aperture
and movement of
some key components
within the eye, that also relate
to the crispness of vision,
that is the acuity of vision,
at both short and long range.
So there are a lot of
technical details there.
In fact, I really hope to
get the great Russell Van
Gelder, or Dr.
Russell Van Gelder,
who's the chair of ophthalmology
at the University of Washington
in Seattle, who is a
world expert in this
and the various aspects,
both molecular and structural
of the ciliary
body and the lens,
and he's an expert in uveitis,
a very interesting topic
in its own, to come
onto the podcast
and talk more about eye health.
And we will do that in the
not too distant future.
Meanwhile, if the first
behavioral protocol
for enhancing and
maintaining eye health
is to make sure that you're
spending at least some time
balancing out the near vision
and far vision during the day,
it also stands to
reason that you
want to get outside for
at least two hours a day,
which I know sounds like a lot,
in order to prevent myopia,
if you're a young person,
and offset the progression of
and maybe even
reverse some myopia,
we don't know yet
based on the data,
but there's some
indication that's
possible, by getting
outside two hours a day.
And the cool thing is, because
many people, including myself,
have a lot of work to do and
we need to be on our phones
quite a lot, or we choose to
be on our phones quite a lot,
this effect of getting sunlight
outdoors during the daytime
for two hours or
more does not seem
to require that you stay
off your phone or tablet,
or that you're looking at
things far in the distance
the entire time.
What this means
is, if you can get
outside onto a patio or a deck
or an outdoor table if you can,
if weather and
conditions permit,
and do some of your phone time
and computer time and reading,
et cetera, outdoors.
Now, if you're already
making an effort
to get outside, hike,
play sports, take walks,
et cetera, that of course
counts towards this two hour
threshold.
And I know this sounds
like a lot, this two hours,
and yet for most people,
it certainly will vary,
depending on time
of year, but I think
striving to get on average
about two hours of outdoor time
as much as you can or
opening a window, which
wouldn't be as good as getting
outside, but opening a window
and trying to get some natural
light exposure to the eye
to trigger the activity,
these intrinsically
photosensitive melanopsin and
retinal ganglion cells, that's
going to be a really good idea
in trying to offset and maybe
even reverse some vision loss.
Now, the other
behavioral protocols
which have shown to be useful
in terms of maintaining
or improving vision relate to
the musculature around the eye
and the control of the
movement of the lens.
And actually, the lens of the
eye has its own flexibility.
It's a really, really
interesting structure.
I'll geek out on
this far too long
if I don't prevent
myself from doing so,
but the lens is just incredible.
The fact that it has a
specific structure of proteins
like crystallines and
things of that sort
and that it can still derive
nourishment from blood flow
but does not actually have
vasculature within it.
So it's not-- if you notice
the lens of your eyes
and filled with blood
vessels and capillaries
because it needs
light to pass through,
super interesting
structure I think
the only violation of what
I just said is the manatee.
Those pigs are underwater,
elephant-like creatures
that I think were
or are endangered.
Down in Florida, they
were getting chopped up
by speedboats, but
I think now there's
some effort to preserve
those big gentle giants.
The manatee, as I recall, has
a vascularized lens, which
is why their eyes look opaque.
It looks like they
have cataracts.
In any case, you're
not a manatee.
You have no blood vessel
supply to the lens.
Keeping that lens clear
is vital nowadays.
They can do lens replacement.
There's really a pretty
incredible progress
in the realm of ophthalmology
and surgical replacement
of the lens or the cornea,
other aspects of the eye.
But if you're somebody who
is interested in maintaining
your vision, you're
going to want
to maintain the
musculature that controls
the movement and the change
of shape in that lens
and the movement of the eyes,
which allows you to transition
your vision from very
sharp when viewing things
up close to very sharp one
viewing things at a distance.
And this is where some of the
so-called near-far exercises
can be very useful.
So when we did a full
length podcast on eye health
and improving eyesight,
which I invite
you to listen to
if you like, talked
about two different types
of vision exercises that
have been shown to be
useful for improving vision
at a level of acuity
that have a lot
to do with improving the
musculature and the movement
of the eyes and the lens.
And that's what's called
a smooth pursuit task.
So you could go on to YouTube if
you like and put smooth pursuit
eye task and do this for
a few minutes each day
if you're trying to
keep your vision strong.
And what that task involves
is, as the name suggests,
smoothly tracking a small
dot or crosshatch or arrow
on the screen, which
is very different
than the so-called
saccade type eye movements
that we often make.
Saccades are when you dart your
eyes to a particular location
to look at something that
dart it to another location
to look at something.
Microsaccades are
little, tiny versions
of those that were doing
most all of the time,
believe it or not.
When you look at a
visual scene or image,
if you did not have those
little microsaccades,
your brain would adapt
or would attenuate
to whatever you were looking
at, and the visual image
would actually
disappear, which really
speaks to how important it is
that your perceptions change
in order to maintain them.
This is very similar
to where if something
is placed on your
hand, say a finger,
you'll notice that
change, but then
if you leave it there
for a short while,
you'll forget that it's
there because the cells there
have adapted out.
There's no change.
So your nervous system is
largely responding to change.
This is also why when
you walk into a room
and you'll often
notice a novel smell,
let's hope it's a good
smell, after a few minutes
or so, you don't notice
the smell anymore
because your olfactory
system adapted that away.
So a lot of that
adaptation is prevented
by those little microsaccades.
And the macrosaccades,
the bigger saccades,
are really for moving
your eyes around
to look for things
in visual space.
Smooth pursuit is a
very particular kind
of visual behavior that you
can do in a smooth pursuit
task and zero cost.
Costs a little bit of time I
suppose to do this on YouTube.
And most any of them will do.
We can provide a link in the
show note captions of one
that we like or
several that we like,
but by doing that smooth
pursuit task for a bit each day,
maybe just a minute
or two, you're
maintaining your ability through
the musculature of the eye
to do smooth pursuit.
And, of course, you
do smooth pursuit
when you move about
your day, but for people
that are trying to offset or
reverse vision loss, doing
some additional deliberate
smooth pursuit exercises
can be useful.
The other visual exercise
that can be very useful
is the so-called
near-far exercise.
So this is best
accomplished, I think,
by holding out a pen or
pencil in front of your eyes,
in front of your head, and
focusing very intensely
through what's called a vergence
eye movement, where you bring
both eyes to the tip of
the pen and then moving
that pen closer and closer
and closer to your eyes,
where you get close
enough that you actually
have to deliberately
bring your eyes--
for those of you
listening, this is
what I'm doing right now-- to
the point where it's blurry
and you can no longer hold
it in sharp, crisp relief.
You can't see it
sharply that is.
And then you can move it
out a little bit distance
and play right
around that threshold
where it's hard to
keep it in focus
and then move it back out again.
And then in doing that for even
a minute or two, you'll find
is a bit of a
strain on your eyes,
but you can actually
build up the musculature
and the neuromuscular
connections that allow you
to do that more efficiently.
And that has been
shown to improve
certain aspects of vision,
especially when people
are diligent about
doing those exercises,
not necessarily every
day, but let's say
three days a week or so.
They can be very fast.
I actually find
them fun for reasons
that escape me entirely.
Now, how close you
can bring that object
and still maintain
it in sharp focus
will vary from person to person
based on a number of things.
First of all, how healthy
and well-performing
their neural retina
is, whether or not
they have myopia or hyperopia,
nearsightedness, et cetera,
whether or not, for
instance, you're
like me and you have a fairly
close inter pupillary distance,
or whether or not
you're more wall eyed
and you have your eyes
set further apart.
All those things will
dictate the exact performance
of that task, but
nonetheless, it's
a very useful task to do when
trying to maintain or improve
vision.
Now, of course, there are
a lot more behavioral tools
that one could use to
maintain or enhance vision.
I'm really touching
on the biggest
and what I consider the
most important ones that
are most accessible to
people without the need
for any fancy equipment at all.
And if you want to learn more
about other behavioral tools
that one can use to
maintain or enhance vision,
please see the episode
that we did on eyesight.
You can simply go
to hubermanlab.com.
Put into the search
function, eyesight or vision.
It'll take you right to it.
In fact, everything on that
website is keyword indexed
and will take you to the
various episodes and time stamps
that you're interested in
according to that keyword.
Now, the person who asked
this question, who by the way,
is Page Singer, thank
you Page Singer,
and the question
got a lot of upvotes
because apparently there's
a lot of interest in this,
understandably so, asked about
nutrition and supplements
for maintaining or
improving vision.
That could be a very
lengthy conversation,
but let's just summarize
it with a few brief points
that we know stand based on
the clinical and scientific
research.
We've all heard that carrots
are good for your eyes.
Well, it's not carrots per se
that are good for your eyes.
It's vitamin A that's
essential for the so-called
phototransduction cascade.
The phototransduction
cascade is the process
by which the
photoreceptors, which
are in the back of the retina,
at least if you're human,
they're in the
back of the retina,
take photons, light
energy, and convert it
into electrical
signals that's then
conveyed to the other cells
and neurons within the retina
and then passed into the brain
to create visual perceps.
Most people can't get enough
of this fat soluble vitamin,
we call vitamin
A, by making sure
that they eat at least some
dark green leafy vegetables.
And that they do
that in their closest
to raw form, maybe
cooked a little bit
but not overly cooked.
There are other sources
of vitamin A out.
There you can look those
up online just for sources
of vitamin A. Most people will
be able to get enough vitamin
A from their nutrition and won't
require it from a supplement,
provided that it's not present
at excessively high levels
in a foundational supplement
or vitamin mineral supplement.
Getting some
additional vitamin A
from a foundational supplement
or vitamin mineral supplement
is probably not going to be
an issue unless you really
take in far too
much of that vitamin
A. It could potentially
provide some insurance.
But, again, I think most
people can get enough vitamin
A from their diet if
they are taking carrots
or to eat the foods
that contain vitamin A,
green leafy
vegetables being one.
The other food that's known to
be highly enriched in vitamin A
is liver, one of my least
favorite foods regardless
of what animal that
liver comes from.
Liver is somewhat of a
popular/controversial organ
meat in the nutrition
space for reasons
that aren't interesting,
for sake of this discussion
anyway I suppose
for those of you
that like liver, you could
eat a little bit of liver
every once in a while.
It is rich in a number of things
that are beneficial to health,
although for you
vegans out there,
I'm sure you'll want to
avoid liver entirely.
I avoid liver
because I just simply
don't like the way it tastes.
Maybe once or twice
I've tasted liver
that was appetizing to me.
And it can be OK, but it's just
not, or at least by my read it,
can be OK, but it's not
a food that I actively
seek out, order, or prepare
for myself on a regular basis.
So fortunately, there are other
sources of vitamin A as well.
And, again, I just invite you to
all put into a web search food
sources of vitamin
and figure out
how to get your daily
dose of vitamin A
by taking in foods
that you like for you.
And then in terms
of supplementation
of things that can enhance
vision, this is a newer area.
And frankly, it's an area
where most of the data
point to some supplements
that can potentially
be beneficial in certain
disease conditions.
So for instance, in fairly
progressed age-related macular
degeneration.
Age-related macular
degeneration is
fairly common, or more
common than we would like,
we should say.
And it does appear
that supplementing
with certain things like lutein,
which is present in eggs,
or egg yolks in particular,
especially egg yolks that
aren't overly cooked, or
that can be supplemented
can potentially help
with some instances
of age-related
macular degeneration.
But the data on this
are still emerging.
I consulted with our
chair of ophthalmology
at Stanford about lutein
and some of the other things
that you'll see out there, like
zeaxanthin and astaxanthins.
And these xanthins come
from certain fruits
like blueberries, and they're
present in supplements
and things of that sort.
The consensus I
got talking to him
and talking to some
other ophthalmologists
are that if you're really
aiming to get a healthy diet,
you're avoiding
cigarette smoking.
And by healthy
diet I mean getting
sufficient amounts of
vitamin A and lutein
through food sources.
Again, you can look up where
those food sources are,
egg yolks just
being one of them.
Well, then chances
are you're not
going to need to supplement
with lutein or the zeaxanthins
or the astaxanthins.
However, I have heard anecdotal
reports from a number of people
that they'll start taking a
supplement for eye health,
there are a number
of them out there--
we are not, as a
podcast, affiliate
with any of those eye health
supplements by the way--
and people are reporting
enhanced vision.
I receive emails all
the time that say, I'm
taking this lutein at
20 milligrams per day,
and there I should mention
that the dosage that's
been explored in a
couple of studies
is 10 to 20 milligrams per day.
Again, you could
get that from foods.
You could go above that
if you're more cavalier,
or you could go toward
the lower end of that,
10 to 20 milligrams per
day, if you are somebody
who's more conservative.
I should say.
Well, there aren't
people out there who are,
looking at lutein, they
think it's fairly safe,
and they're taking
higher dosages of lutein,
so 20 to 30 milligrams per day.
They're also taking
supplements that
contain zeaxanthins
and astaxanthins
and are reporting anecdotally
that their vision is enhanced.
I don't dispute those
claims, but as of now, there
aren't many papers, I
could only find about 4,
3 really solid ones and
then a fourth, that point
to the specific
disease instances
where supplementing with lutein,
zeaxanthin, or astaxanthin
can be beneficial for slowing
the progression of things
like advanced onset age-related
macular degeneration.
And the degree of offset for
that macular degeneration
was slight.
It wasn't enormous, but
it was robust enough
that it warranted
reporting in the paper.
Or things like Lieber's, which
is a particular eye disease.
It impacts a whole different
set of systems in the eye.
So basically, what
I'm trying to say
is, when it comes to supplements
to support eye health,
make sure you're getting enough
vitamin A from your diet.
If you're not, consider
supplementation
or consider changing
your diet somewhat
to make sure you can get
that lutein and vitamin A.
And if you are interested in
it, and it's within your budget,
I don't know of any
evidence that supplementing
with additional lutein,
zeaxanthin, and astaxanthin
can be dangerous at all.
So for those of
you that are really
interested in maintaining
or improving your vision,
that might be an area
that you want to explore.
I personally am not
taking lutein, zeaxanthin,
or astaxanthin, at
least not at this time.
I do take a
foundational supplement,
which is my source of vitamin A
in addition to my food sources.
But I don't suffer
from vision loss
anywhere, readers at night,
and I have for a long time.
I have a little bit
of a muscular weakness
in one of my eyes that
originated in childhood.
So occasionally, if I get
very fatigued, one of my eyes
will deviate a little
bit, a little bit
of almost strabismus,
especially if I've been awake
for very long periods of time.
It tends to recover once I
get a good night's sleep.
Some of you that
have experienced
this, where you
have one eye that
might just drift a little bit.
I could do this for
the camera if you want.
OK, this is weird.
I used to do this to my
sister across the table when
we were at a friend's
houses for dinner.
So I can actually
move one of my eyes
in like this, which
actually just reflects
that there's a extraocular
muscle closer to my nose.
It's rather weak, which
allows me to do that.
I can't do it so well
with the opposite eye.
Anyway, now I need to
blink to clear my vision.
But the point is that,
if you're somebody
who has a slightly
deviating eye, slightly,
often if you go to the
ophthalmologist or optometrist,
they're going to give
you a prism lens which
is going to redirect the
image onto that slightly
deflected eyeball.
One thing you'll
really want to discuss
with that ophthalmologist or
optometrist is whether or not
there are exercises that
you could do to overcome
that issue without the need
for a prism because what I saw
and what many other people see
when they put on a prism lens
is that indeed it can
line up their vision
or their visual
perception better,
but indeed, it can lead
to progressive weakening
of the muscle
further and further.
So then that eyeball starts to
deviate further and further.
And that raises a larger
question, which is,
should we wear
corrective lenses?
In fact, if you
go online, you'll
find or hear about
these examples
of people that stopped wearing
their corrective lenses,
their glasses or
contacts, in order
to bring their vision
back or improve
their vision on their own.
Now, if your vision
is quite impaired,
you're going to need
corrective lenses or contacts.
However, there are a
number of people out there
who find that if their
vision is somewhat impaired,
that forcing themselves to
view things at a distance
to do smooth pursuit,
to do near far,
and to make sure that they're
getting adequate nutrition
and things of that
sort, can all sum
to help offset some of the
visual impairment that would
occur if they were to just
pop glasses on their face
and rely on the
corrective lenses
in order to focus the light onto
the correct area within the eye
onto the neural retina.
So I'm not telling people
to throw off or get rid
of their corrective
lenses and contacts,
but you can be overly reliant
on these things, like a crutch,
in a way that perhaps you want
to do a little bit of work
to try and overcome
and then maybe work
with a weaker prescription.
And certainly, in the
case of prism lenses,
what I mentioned before
is a real consideration.
It's one I'm very familiar with.
So as a last but I
think very important
and exciting feature of visual
improvement is red light.
I talked a little bit about this
on the episode of the Huberman
Lab podcast all about
light and health.
There's some really
spectacular, I
think I consider it spectacular,
many other people consider
it spectacular, research out
of University College London.
And the work I'm referring
to is Glenn Jeffrey's work.
I've known Glenn
for a long time.
These are animal studies,
and now two human studies,
exploring how exposure to
red light early in the day
can offset some of the
vision loss related
to age-related macular
degeneration, or simply
age-related visual decline.
There's a whole
mechanism here that's
discussed in that episode,
but it has to do with the fact
that red light and near-infrared
light, together, or maybe
even separately, when viewed
for even just a minute
to 3 minutes once, or maybe
two or three times per week
maximum, can actually
reduce the number of what
are called reactive oxygen
species in the photoreceptors
that convert photons
into electrical signals
the rest of the visual
system can understand.
So that's a mouthful.
Basically what they found was,
for people 40 years or older,
if they viewed this red
light at a distance of about
a foot and a half,
although I wouldn't
get too specific with this, for
a few minutes each week total,
they were able to offset
some of the vision loss
within a particular
domain of vision.
And I don't have time
to go into the details
here because I do that in
the Light for Health episode,
but you have different types
of photoreceptors, cones,
and rods.
You have different types
of cone photoreceptors
that respond to different
wavelengths of light,
short, medium, and long
wavelengths of light
so-called blue,
green, and red cones,
they're sometimes called.
When these people who
are 40 years or older
viewed red light on a consistent
basis early in the day,
and it did have to
be early in the day,
there was a real
circadian effect there,
there was a offset of
some of the vision loss
that would normally occur
in a particular wavelength
of light range that resulted in
better visual acuity overall.
So if you're very concerned
about your vision,
or you're into red light
therapies, et cetera,
there are a number of different
red light devices out there.
At some future point,
the Huberman Lab podcast
may partner with one of
these red light companies.
So right now, I'm not going
to mention any of them
in particular.
They're prominent online.
What you're looking for is a
red light unit that provides
red light and maybe far--
near infrared-- excuse
me-- light as well.
So something in the 650 to
720 ish nanometer range.
So really it's going to
look red or almost invisible
to you if it's really
far into the infrared.
And you'll want to view
that at a distance of about
a foot and a half to 2 feet.
And you don't want
it to be so bright
that it's painful to
look at because you
don't want to damage your eyes.
But that's essentially what
they used in these studies
from the Jeffrey lab.
And they showed some
pretty impressive
offset of some of the
aspects of vision loss
in these people 40 and older.
So that's an area
that you may want
to explore as well, especially
for folks 40 and older.
And, again, this
red light exposure
had to be done early in the day.
So hopefully, that collection
of behavioral tools near, far,
smooth pursuit, some of the
discussion about lutein,
nutrition, vitamin A,
supplementation, zeaxanthins,
astaxanthins, getting two
hours of light exposure
outside, sunlight exposure,
get outside to do some
of your work, and perhaps even
deliberate red light exposure
for certain people can be
used to offset your concerns
and your action
potential vision loss
and maybe even improve your
vision regardless of what age
you are.
Everything I
described is supported
from the Peer-reviewed
literature.
And, again, if you want to
get the deep dive on mechanism
and further information
about dosages,
please check out the
episode on eyesight
and improving your eyesight and
the Light for Health episode
again at hubermanlab.com.
Thank you for joining
for the beginning
of this Ask Me Anything episode.
To hear the full episode and to
hear future episodes of these
Ask Me Anything sessions, plus
to receive transcripts of them
and transcripts of the Huberman
Lab podcast standard channel
and premium tools not
released anywhere else,
please go to
hubermanlab.com/premium.
Just to remind you why we
launched the Huberman Lab
podcast premium channel,
it's really twofold.
First of all, it's
to raise support
for the standard Huberman
Lab podcast channel, which,
of course, will still be
continued to be released
every Monday in full length.
We are not going to
change the format
or anything about the
standard Huberman Lab podcast,
and to fund research, in
particular research done
on human beings, so
not animal models
but on human beings,
which I think we all agree
is the species that we
are most interested in.
And we are going to
specifically fund
research that is aimed
toward developing
further protocols for mental
health, physical health,
and performance.
And those protocols
will be distributed
through all channels, not
just the premium channel
but through all channels,
Huberman Lab podcast
and other media channels.
So the idea here is to give
you information to your burning
questions, in depth, and
allow you the opportunity
to support the kind
of research that
provides those kinds of
answers in the first place.
Now, an especially exciting
feature of the premium channel
is that the tiny
foundation has generously
offered to do dollar-for-dollar
match on all funds raised
for research through
the premium channel.
So this is a terrific
way that they're
going to amplify whatever funds
come in through the premium
channel to further support
research for science
and science-related tools for
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
If you'd like to sign up for the
Huberman Lab Premium channel,
again, there's a cost
of $10 per month,
or you can pay $100 up
front for the entire year.
That will give you
access to all the AMAs.
You can ask questions and get
answers to your questions,
and you'll, of course, get
answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well.
There will also be some premium
content such as transcripts
of the AMAs and various
transcripts and protocols
of Huberman Lab podcast episodes
and not found elsewhere.
And, again, you'll be
supporting research
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
You can sign up for the
premium channel by going
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Again, that's
hubermanlab.com/premium.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]